[Applaudissements]
mais là on va pas le faire
vous allez bien
ok
bon bah ça y est on y est on m'a dit de
rester dans le petit cercle rouge
ok je dois vous parler aujourd'hui on
m'a pas demandé dans la thématique c'est
le futur et donc évidemment le futur des
mathématiques
le futur franchement honnêtement qui
veut prédire le futur est-ce que on
pourrait dire dans une boule de cristal
pour essayer de deviner ça sera quoi
l'avenir l'avenir des mathématiques même
lui-même aussi est-ce qu'on peut essayer
de deviner mais je vais faire comme un
fait mon collègue tout à l'heure pour
essayer de deviner le futur ce que je
vous propose c'est d'aller regarder un
petit peu dans le passé on va faire de
la natation scientifique il analyse des
données possible de deviner les données
qu'il y aura demain nous on va faire la
même chose je vous propose de remonter
il y a 123 ans 123 ans pour ceux qui ont
fait des maths ça nous emmène
ça nous emmène en 1900 on est à Paris on
est là
on est en 1900 on est à Paris et vous
savez ce qui s'est passé à Paris en 1900
un truc incroyable ça s'appelle
l'Exposition Universelle alors qu'est-ce
que c'est que l'exposition universelle
c'est le moment où l'humanité c'est
réuni et a dit mais qu'est-ce qu'on a
fait et où on va à ce moment-là en 1900
déjà l'humanité dans son intégralité
c'est dit mais qu'est ce sera notre
futur qu'est-ce que ça sera le futur
alors les ingénieurs sont réunis et puis
il y a un mec un fort diminue avec son
odeur à combustion ça ça le futur il y a
les artistes qui se sont réunis c'est
quoi aujourd'hui l'impressionnisme c'est
quoi ces courants de penser c'est quoi
la littérature les architectes se sont
réunis c'est quoi notre technique de
construction comment est-ce qu'on fait
etc il y a il y a mon architecte
français pas très connu juste à
vaisselle il a dit de regarder pour
l'exposition universelle à l'endroit
d'exposition universelle ce qu'on va
faire c'est qu'on va construire une
grande tour en métal pour montrer qu'on
est capable de faire des trucs et du
coup son objectif c'était vraiment sur
le Champ de Mars à l'endroit de
l'Exposition universelle de construire
une tour pour montrer ce qu'on est
capable de faire en architecture elle
aurait dû être démonter après du coup on
n'est pas démonter elle est là-bas en
tous ceux qui sont bien placés peuvent
la voir c'est lui de temps en temps mais
elle est restée pour le plus grand
plaisir la team et tous les tous les
trucs tous les touristes
les mathématiciens aussi se sont réunis
ils sont tous réunis ils ont discuté
débattus réfléchis qui sont battus un
petit peu mais c'est quoi ce qu'on a
fait avant et c'est quoi faire quoi on
doit aller après déjà en 1900 les
mathématiciens sont tous réunis pour se
demander qu'est-ce que ça sera le futur
des mathématiques et ils étaient tous
réunis autour d'eux du Dieu de l'époque
pour reprendre ce que disait mon
collègue tout à l'heure c'était ta vie
divert c'est ta vie diverses
mathématicien allemand presque David et
Berne j'aurais dû mais non David liberté
après des débats des discussions on a
fait une liste de 23 problèmes qu'on
appelle les 23 problèmes de lait et donc
en 1900 les mathématiens étaient déjà en
train de se demander mais faire quoi on
doit aller qu'est-ce qu'on doit faire
après alors sur ces 23 problèmes de
hiver il y a quatre types de tissus
possibles il y a des problèmes qui ont
été résolus il y a des problèmes qui
devront la démontrer que c'était pas
possible il y a des problèmes même
regarder ce problème là on va lire pour
faire un peu de maths quand même tous
sous ensemble infini de réel peut être
mis en bijection avec l'ensemble des
entiers naturels ou avec l'ensemble des
réels lui-même vous avez trois heures
mathématiquement à quelque chose
d'encore plus profond plus subtil c'est
ce qui a résolu ce problème c'est le
théorème d'investissement d'un
décidabilité de gueuler qui dit en fait
on pourra jamais démontrer que c'est
possible et on pourra jamais démontrer
que c'est impossible ça que on n'a pas
résolu ce problème on a dit on ne pourra
jamais le résultat c'est encore plus
profond que
et il y a des problèmes aujourd'hui en
2023 qui sont toujours pas résolus mais
avant d'arriver aujourd'hui le 10 mars
depuis le 23
dans l'hôtel Novotel on peut voir on va
dire à Paris avec un public en folie
avant d'arriver là je vous propose de
d'avancer un petit peu dans le temps en
1900 on va s'entendre plus tard et 100
ans plus tard re-exposition universelle
on est américain et là encore une fois
l'humanité se réunit mais qu'est-ce
qu'on a et vers quoi
dans cet endroit-là on a parlé déjà de
métaphe on parlait déjà de
crypto-monnaies FFT on parlait déjà de
enfin il y a même eu le nid d'oiseau à
Pékin qui était construit pour savoir il
y a plein but plein de choses qui ont
été faites et aussi les mathématiciens
ont l'an 2000 se sont réunis ils ont dit
mais qu'est-ce que ça sera l'avenir des
mathématiques en l'an 2000 on se posait
la question de qu'est-ce que ça sera
déjà l'avenir des mathématiques alors il
y a des problèmes qui ont été résolus
comme je vous l'ai dit les problèmes
qu'on peut démontrer qu'ils sont pas
résolubles et puis il y a certains
problèmes qui sont nés d'ailleurs en
cours de ces 100 ans il y a certains
problèmes qui reviennent à liberté et
finalement il y a un institut américain
qui s'appelle l'Institut clé qui a fait
une liste des problèmes qui seront le
futur des mathématiques les 7 problèmes
dans l'an 2000 donc les 7 problèmes du
millénaire la conjecture de ville
schween d'ailleurs la conjecture dehors
des équations de la testo le P problème
et le NP problème la sur le Point Carré
l'hypothèse de rhuman et la théorie les
sept problèmes du Yémen et là déjà on
est en l'an 2000 on commence un tout
petit peu à toucher le futur des
mathématiques on est on avance un peu on
est en 2007 en 2007 il y a un de ses
problèmes qui a été résolué
résolue par un mathématicien russe
Grégory pèle romane
qui donc
sur ces 7 problèmes institut crée la
meilleure chèque de 1 million de dollars
un bon moyen de gagner de l'argent quand
même des problèmes pas mal et Grégory
Perry
il a refusé le binôme de long folie
gêner je sais pas beaucoup d'idées c'est
un lieu de débat mais il a refusé
millions d'hommes
sur ces problèmes
c'est des problèmes mathématiques ou
mathématiques regardez ce que ça dit la
conjecture de BIOS d'ailleurs la
conjecture de Auch Edge les équations de
naviestoque on dirait que c'est des
agences immobilières ces trucs là c'est
bon on arrive même pas à comprendre le
temps aux exposer je vais pas vous les
expliquer sont difficiles à comprendre
je les comprends même pas tous mais
c'est des problèmes pour les
mathématiciens qu'est-ce que c'est en
vrai l'avenir des mathématiques pour le
commun des mortels pour les gens qui
font pas de maths qu'est-ce que ça veut
dire l'avenir des mathématiques regardez
par exemple l'hypothèse de Riemann cette
image pour essayer d'expliquer c'est un
grand monstre avec plein de petits
médecins mathématiens qui essaient de
résoudre ça mais l'hypothèse de Rayman
demain si on arrive à la résoudre c'est
un des problèmes ça y est on est arrivé
aujourd'hui penser que deviner ce que ça
sera demain si on arrive à la résoudre
l'hypothèse de finale on éclate
complètement le S de HTTPS tous les
protocoles de sécurité cryptographie
sont morts demain l'hypothèse de mal
elle tombe la sécurité qui existe
aujourd'hui qui utilise des nombres
premiers donc un vieux mathématicien
aussi déjà jadis qui avait fait un truc
qui avait trouvé une connexion entre les
nombres premiers et cette hypothèse de
Rima tout ça sa peur je vais pas vous
faire un cours de mathématiques pour
vous expliquer ce que c'est que
l'hypothèse de rivale c'est pas
inaccessible c'est quelque chose si vous
avez vous êtes tous un peu scientifique
dans la salle oui un petit peu vous
savez tout ce que c'est qu'une fonction
d'accord l'hypothèse de Riemann ça dit
il y a une fonction une fonction très
simple on va l'appeler aux États parce
que c'est son nom
il y a une fonction étape et on veut
étudier alors est-ce que si je vous
montre d'étudier une fonction c'est quoi
vos trucs que vous faites on dérive que
tu dis les limites les asymptotes ou
toutes les saloperies qu'on a appris en
terminale qui de base quand on les a
convenu à quoi ça sert ben voilà par
exemple le genre de trucs à quoi ça sert
à résoudre l'hypothèse et le Survival
dans son hypothèse si on veut résoudre
si vous voulez vous intéresser vous
c'est il sera quoi quand je fais pour
réduire le nombre de dollars il y a
cette fonction et je cherche à trouver
les états de Z = 0 je veux vous donner
les X tels que vous êtes allés x tels
que les États de x = 0 vous le faites
vous gagnez un groupe voilà les millions
c'est plus compliqué etc mais encore une
fois bon ça c'est compréhensible mais
c'est des problèmes pour les
mathématiciens qu'est-ce que c'est en
fait de l'avenir des mathématiques pour
nous et comment des mortels qui
utilisons peut-être les marques mais un
petit peu genre ça c'est des maths
là-dedans il y a des maths là-dedans il
y a des matchs c'est l'utilisation une
application des mathématiques c'est quoi
l'avenir pratique des mathématiques pas
l'avenir pour les mathématiciens
qu'est-ce que ça sera le futur des
mathématiques
je vais vous donner un exemple
j'ai soutenu ma thèse en 2012
[Applaudissements]
classique on fait sa licence on fait son
master on fait son doctorat pendant son
doctorat ça dure 3 ans 4 ans 5 ans 6 ans
7 ans même minimum trois ans on fait une
activité de recherche pendant cette
période là moi ça a duré 4 ans on passe
4 ans où on passe on sort c'est un peu
une métamorphose de de du statut
d'étudiant pour devenir le chercheur
pour devenir admettre le doigt dans
l'inconnu essayer de découvrir
d'inventer d'être créatif essayer de
voilà vraiment dans la nouveauté de
faire quelque chose que personne n'a
jamais fait alors c'est un moment un peu
éprouvant c'est difficile il faut
vraiment être dans la nouveauté faut
être dans voilà bref c'est un moment
trois années quatre années voire plus où
on se transforme et en général on
soutient s'intéresse et puis ça se passe
bien et en général après la thèse il y a
un événement un moment un petit peu
sympa le pot de thèse c'est pas très
joyeux et on se réunit tous et puis on
voit un coup on mange une chips et on
est content parce que ça y est je suis
docteur en mathématiques c'est passé
j'ai survécu et ces trois amis
après maintenant
90 90% des personnes qui sont venu moi
me voir m'ont dit c'est bien
[Musique]
oui c'est quand même un petit peu oui
parce qu'en fait l'avenir des
mathématiques ce que c'est de faire
comprendre c'est que l'avenir des
mathématiques et déjà on peut ici on a
déjà le droit dedans on va je vais vous
donner un autre exemple qui va peut-être
un peu plus vous parler bon il faut
descendre l'exemple il faut que tu sois
alenturier je pense que c'est qu'un mot
qui doit pas vous connaissez à la tuerie
le pire de l'informatique le père de
l'informatique c'est lui qui a inventé
presque le premier ordinateur c'est lui
qui a pensé ça doit être quoi une
intelligence artificielle ça doit être
quoi le test de Turing les machines de
Turing Turing c'est le père de
l'informatique tuning il est mort dans
les années 50 52 53 la date de naissance
officielle de l'informatique la table de
naissance quand on fait time dans les
machines c'est le premier janvier
1970 après la mort de l'inventeur du
père de l'informatique en fait les
concepts mathématiciens les concepts
mathématiques qui sont là aujourd'hui
sont déjà un peu le futur des
mathématiques un tout petit peu tous ces
concepts c'est l'intelligence
artificielle par Google images que je
vous ai données là sur le pour présenter
ce stage j'ai utilisé une petite
application c'est intelligence
artificielle et puis on rentre des mots
clés et puis ça donne des images donc
par exemple pour avoir la première salle
plus je l'ai montré j'ai tapé dans mon
truc une vieille date qui prophétise la
lumière des mathématiques dans une boule
de cristal parfait hier m'a donné m'a
donné une image alors des fois ça
marchait pas très bien par exemple pour
vous montrer ce qui s'est passé genre
réunion mystique de scientifiques en
l'an 2000 qui lancent des sortilèges à
Pékin voilà pour avoir pour avoir une
image qui essaie de représenter
l'Exposition universelle à Pétain bref
l'hypothèse de Rima d'un gigantesque
monstre tué par un petit tophétif bon
voilà on essaie l'intelligence
artificielle c'est peut-être un petit
peu ça aussi l'avenir des mathématiques
ah ça existe déjà les concepts
mathématiques les objets de ma thèse ce
que j'ai fait dans ma thèse
ça sert à rien à personne aujourd'hui à
part pour des mathématiciens pour les
10% qui ont compris ce que j'ai raconté
mais peut-être que dans 20 ans ça va
servir peut-être que dans 50 ans ça fait
peut-être que dans 100 ans ça va servir
peut-être que dans 100 ans ouais est-ce
que j'ai fait ça va
IR le commun des mortels qui veulent
utiliser mathématiques dans leur
quotidien regardez aujourd'hui avec une
lumière sur un téléphone j'arrive à
générer des images quel est l'étudiant
n'a pas utilisé pété pour faire son
contrôle tout à l'heure
on y est mais ça ces outils là qui ont
été pensés par tout le monde développé
par la suite
comme l'intelligence artificielle ils
existent déjà aujourd'hui tous ces
concepts mathématiques le les
probabilités les statistiques les objets
linéaires les théories de l'information
les calculs différentiels les graves les
réseaux les intégrales tous ces trucs là
sont des outils qui existent aujourd'hui
ils créent déjà culture mais on le sait
pas encore mais il crée le futur
aujourd'hui
[Applaudissements]